yeah we're working out what keeping it
aspiring to be better you know
just because one a road doesn't mean
we're not doing the 4 a.m. club but it's
actually the 2 a.m. 2 p.m. club because
we're changing it to the 2 p.m. Club
because we slept till about noon because
we were Java act so also we're not a
lunatic
we're not waking up at 4 a.m. or 2:30
a.m. cuz that's [ __ ] crazy and we're
not a crazy person but we're still doing
all that stuff with the barbells and the
dumbbells so it's PI to be better all
right it's 2 p.m. because I'm not a
crazy person working out at 2:00 p.m.
just did a bunch of jumps box jumps and
then prayed for 20 minutes and then did
some biceps now I'm gonna go play golf
for 15 minutes I want to come back you
know jumping jacks just say to snack
shirtless in the cafeteria after I could
play golf and it did some push-ups and I
just throw up all over the place and now
on to on to back curls it's gonna just
just went on the elliptical took my
pants off I don't have pants on took the
ecliptic all started bleeding out of my
nose wipe their off played golf at 2 for
4 minutes
aspire to be better